Giờ ăn được giây năm 2014, là cai viên là một trong những công chính năm lựa chọn điểm.
Vừa đáp ứng được việc dài toa công sốt của các giãn điện của tây bác ươi điểm hiện tại và tương lai,
vừa sẵn sàng trong những nhập khổ điện từ chú của khi đến nằm có như cầu.
Giờ ăn đang bước vào giải đảng thì công nước dút với tâm hoàn thành sửp tiến độ.
Vong ai bôi chính tháng tâm, theo chỉ đạo mới nhất của tụi tưởng chính phổ,
sướng hơn gần 2 tuần sồ về kế hách băng đầu là buổi tháng tâm, nó nghe hiểu khu trong hai bây làm.
Hơn hai nghìn gắn bộ khi sư công dình định cho các nhà thầu,
cùng thiết địa máy móc hiện nại đang ngày đêm bám chủ chính công trường
đưa công chính lần lượt vượt qua các đường ngon tỉ lộ.
Theo đại diện các nhà thầu, nghiệm đột phá vệ tỉ lộ của dự ăn này chính là dài pháp gục cả sản xuất và sư lắp trong cùng một lỗi thầu.
Như vậy, việc phố hợp dựa các đường vị đã nhìn nhàng hơn, ăn hi hơn, chẳng đúc tình trạng mống trâu cô thay cô chương mống như các dự ăn chức đây.
Chỉ còn khoảng 1 tháng nữa phải hòn thành công trình, chứ đầu tư đã và đang tăng cường giám sát,
điều phố nghiệm nhàng rửa các khu, các nhà thầu đang ngày đêm bám chủ chính công trường,
phần đầu đứa công trình hòn thành đục tỉ lộ.